[Music]
okay everybody i am so thrilled today
because i am joined by the writer and
director of resident evil welcome to
raccoon city which is in theaters
wednesday johannes roberts how you doing
today hey i'm good man thank you
yeah man i'm so pumped to talk to you
i'm a huge resident evil fan i'm excited
to talk behind the man behind the camera
for this um so
just you've gone on record saying you've
based this film off the first two games
how do you decide
how much to keep from the games in the
film and what to kind of cut
oh yeah yeah that's a tricky one i think
very early on it became very clear this
is the path forward to go back to the
the to the first two games to tell
something that was scary and recreate to
be honest for me as a fan recreate the
feelings i had when i first played the
game as a student
um
and then really the thing that actually
while i was writing it well you know we
decided on this is the way forward and
we were sort of talking about different
avenues we could go and things we should
include and not include and then uh
capcom dropped the remake of the second
game
and i started playing that and i was
just like guys this is this is the movie
man i mean this is [ __ ] amazing sorry
i don't know if i can swear
um it just blew my mind you know the
atmosphere the cinematic
uh the the visuals were just so
cinematic the atmosphere was just
incredible
the gameplay was amazing i was just like
oh my god this is i love this so that
became like a cornerstone of
of what the movie would be and then it
was just sort of yeah sort of working
out how to bring in the elements of the
first two games
together into one sort of night of
terror
yeah and that's exciting that you've
played the remake too by the way because
that that is the best version to play so
let's go to that yeah yeah yeah um so
what character's point of view can we
expect to kind of be the primary one in
this film and what went into that
decision for you
well what i wanted to do is i want to do
a proper i'm a massive john carpenter
fan so i the way the way i sort of
viewed this was like
uh i saw precinct 13 with zombies so
it was an ensemble piece i i i wanted
the iconic characters i wanted chris i
wanted claire wesker
leon
and jill all to come together kind of
for the first time and it's like an
origin movie and and then
we would see them in different like with
i sort of with claire she's the drifter
coming into town so that's how we sort
of introduced the world with leon he's
he's sort of
he's this disheveled hungover
anti-hero that just wakes up uh on his
first day on the beat and
and it's through him that we kind of
explore raccoon city for the first time
and you've got you know you've got chris
and jill and and wesco who these small
town guys that never left there that
this kind of
small town stephen king style
version of raccoon city so each person
sort of brings their own sort of
point of view and
uh
uh sort of carves their own little world
out into this narrative that we get it
was a really tricky a jigsaw puzzle like
each one of them is as important as the
other sam and each has something to say
about raccoon and umbrella and the whole
world so it was tricky but but it was
fun
yeah that that's a really good answer
and that's interesting what you're
saying too about the different
characters they all something else to
say but it's it's also cool that like
you know fans really love each one of
these characters you bring up that
you're including so yeah exciting for
fans so what's your reaction though when
you see a fan that's like oh so-and-so
doesn't look exactly like the character
from the game does that bother you and
what is like did you have a certain
strategy for how you were going to cast
no do you know what i uh um yes
obviously that does i don't sort of go
online too much to but i obviously have
to
not not have the internet at all to not
realize that you know that stuff does
get said um
so
yeah the way
the way we approached casting is like
kyle was the first on i i i know alex
arja who directed cruel quite well and
and and i and i watched that and i was
like she'd be perfect for for claire
and and so that kind of formed that and
then we put a first bit of the
cornerstone in but then really it was
all about like when you adapt like this
is a very faithful adaptation of the
first two games this i approached this
material i approached the games as if
they were novels as if i was adapting a
novel and i was faithful and i was in
love with the source material i wasn't
just taking the name and then just
running with it i was in love with the
stories and the characters and
everything going on but the one thing
that i would explain to the cast all and
you know some look like kaya robbie
uh tom look similar to their on-screen
counterparts uh or to the to the game
counterparts but i mean evan couldn't
you know evan does not look like leon
and and hannah does not uh look
desperately like jill
and what i would explain to them is
when each of them came up to me was like
oh should i hold the gun just like uh
jill valentine just just like uh leon
does and should i have frosted tip tips
like uh wesker does and i was like
the world i'm creating with the with the
police station and the mansion and the
and and the orphanage i am creating a
world that is straight out of the games
but you guys are gonna have to be your
own thing you come from the games and
you are those characters but you're
gonna have to imbue those characters
with it
with more than than the games because
that otherwise you've just got the games
on screen and then you might as well
just play the [ __ ] games because they
are yeah yeah no you just stay at home
and be scared shitless out of those
games so i needed to give uh the
audiences a reason to go to the cinema
and and that is that you're watching
uh characters that are human
you know with real real emotions and and
really can you know they have the
essence of the game characters but they
are real living breathing characters and
so that became a really important thing
and so when casting like leon is a
really good example i mean i saw
everybody for that role he was so
important to me because he was the role
that i when i was writing that i got
into
the script with like he i like explored
the world through leon
and he was the ultimate sort of john
carpenter anti-hero in my mind sort of a
little bit
a little bit chaotic a little bit
disheveled you know sort of
out of time out of touch and
i saw everyone and i could not find the
right person for that role and i saw
people that some people came in like
dressed identical to leon with the with
the hair coming down and everything and
then like if i was to shoot it like
visually they would have been perfectly
on but i was just like i'm not doing
some cosplay thing and then and then
evan came in and he read and he just got
the humor but he got that he's a leader
a leading man he's not a comedy sidekick
he got this kind of hung over disheveled
kind of anti-hero vibe and i was like i
want him i want him and i had to fight
and
it just has paid off so well like capcom
absolutely love him like when they
watched that and they saw that he was
just his own thing that that
you know they saw that this movie had a
love of the games but that that they
just had something different to the
games and i think that really excited
them which is very cool for me
yeah i mean that was an amazing answer
and i'm happy i should excite all fans
of the games that are going to see this
movie that you're choosing character
over like you said making it look silly
or cosplay
the right choice and valuing good
performance which is awesome so i can't
wait to see it everybody the film is out
wednesday in theaters johannes thank you
so much for joining me and i hope to
talk to you in the future one day
absolutely lovely chatting